apple just released the iphone 13 and in
this video we're gonna compare it to the
12 and cover every single difference and
answer two important questions first off
should you save a hundred dollars and
just go for the iphone 12 and if you
already have one is it worth upgrading
to the 13. we're gonna cover design
differences displays cpu performance
graphics speakers camera differences and
much more just like last year apple is
not shipping power adapters with these
phones so you will not get one in the
box that means you need to buy one
yourself and instead of buying apples i
would suggest this one from anchor they
are not a sponsor but you can pick this
up for as low as 11 bucks it is small it
gives you full fast charging and the
prongs actually fold making it more
compact i'll go ahead and leave a link
to it down in the video description
below right out of the gate i see some
massive differences the first thing i
got to comment on are these lenses you
guys can see that it's now horizontal
instead of being vertical but look how
much bigger they are uh that is pretty
crazy the flash has been moved the
microphone has been moved the bump
itself is larger and if we look at it
from the side the camera bump sticks out
much more so and that is because the 13
uses the camera system from the 12 pro
max which was 300 more expensive than
the 12 last year it has image
stabilization the sensor shifts we'll
take a look at cameras in just a bit but
that is a big difference now the other
thing i have to say is look at this
color this is the starlight but the back
is super clean it looks white the side
has a nice tint to it i personally am
really digging um the look and the color
of this because of that and the larger
battery the iphone 13 has gotten heavier
you could definitely notice it side by
side holding both of these but i don't
think anybody's going to complain if you
just buy one of them now as far as
dimensions they are pretty much the same
the shape is same the screen size is the
same but apple has made another change
and they moved all the buttons lower on
one side the power button is lower on
the other side the volume and the silent
switch has also moved down meaning that
if you have smaller hands it's going to
be easier to reach the buttons with the
iphone 13. now as far as battery life
apple says that the 13 gets two and a
half hours more of battery life compared
to the 12 that is a huge difference now
of course we haven't tested out for
ourselves so if you want to know the
real world difference in battery life
make sure you guys hit that subscribe
button down below because we will be
putting out a review video along with a
different comparison video for you guys
to check out and with that you guys can
also help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers we would definitely
appreciate it and now taking a look at
the displays we could see that the
biggest difference is the notch for the
first time since nosh came out apple has
changed it
it is now a little bit less wide apple
says it's 20
smaller but it is actually slightly
taller the camera has been repositioned
and the speaker grille for the earpiece
speaker is right there at the top right
next to the frame now with the 13 pro
version of pro max it got a lot louder
as far as speakers so i'm excited to
check out and compare the difference
with these and with that said let's go
ahead and compare the speakers and see
if we have any difference
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comments section below now
to me the difference between these two
phones aren't as big as the difference
between the 12 pro max and the 13 pro
max that was a massive difference but
the 13 is slightly louder and a little
bit more rich than the 12. you do notice
that and along with that the earpiece
speaker the one that's a little bit
higher now is louder as well that's
where a little bit extra volume boost
comes from so it does sound a little bit
more balanced left to right which is
great for watching movies playing games
things like that and now let's compare
the display starting with brightness i
have both set to manual brightness and
as you can see the iphone 13 is brighter
now apple boosted it from 625 nits up to
800 which is the same as last year's
iphone 12 pros so that definitely does
help out especially if you're outside in
the bright sun other than that they are
exactly the same we have the same
contrast the same brightness when you're
watching hdr videos viewing angles color
accuracy everything else is identical
and now let's get into performance the
new iphone 13 has the a15 bionic
processor compared to the a14 but how
much does that really matter well they
both have the same core counts the clock
speed is higher on the new iphone 13 and
as far as ram they are identical both of
them have four gigabytes of ram so let's
go ahead and run geekbench's cpu test
and we'll see how much of a difference
that actually makes all right we have
our results and it looks like as far as
single core we have a performance
difference of about 10 percent and in
multi-core we have a difference of 16
so that is a worthwhile difference you
know you definitely get extra
performance but what this doesn't show
is the energy or power efficiency of the
new a15 so it is actually able to use
the the efficiency cores more often and
that is one reason why it has much
better battery life as well and now
let's go back and we are going to
compare the graphics difference because
we definitely have a change there too
and take a look at that that difference
is probably the smallest difference i've
seen in terms of graphics going from one
generation of iphone to another that is
only 12 percent
difference and that is because this year
apple prioritized the pro models those
actually have five core graphics that
are much much more powerful uh probably
about 50 more powerful than the iphone
12s and with the regular 13 they just
gave it a little bit of improvement but
it's still a four core just like this
one now with this 12 improvement we also
get an improvement in power usage when
you're gaming or doing other tasks that
need the graphics so once again that
just helps you for battery life so
overall i would just say that don't
factor in or don't really care about
what processor these phones have in them
because the difference isn't that big
now one area where we do have a
difference is the storage the iphone 13
comes with 128 gigabytes of storage for
the same price as the 12 last year
whereas the 12 you get 64 for the 100
lower price now with that i also want to
test the performance of your storage so
let's go ahead and run this benchmark
all right guys this is really really
weird
something we didn't expect if we look at
the performance difference it is pretty
big at least in their read speed now
this particular iphone 12 this is a 128
gig i paid the 50 bucks extra to upgrade
and we're getting a thousand five
hundred and eighty megabytes per second
read compared to
867 both with 128 gig so it looks like
this year even though apple gave you
double the storage they put in slower
storage at least in terms of read speed
right is a little bit faster we're
looking at about 120 140 megabytes per
second faster and then i also have my 13
pro which has 128 gigs
and this one is much faster we also have
that 1580
and then the right speed is even faster
than that so if you do buy a pro phone
you get faster speeds but with iphone 13
expect a little bit slower read speeds
and now let's talk about the cameras and
we do have some pretty big differences
now the selfie camera didn't change in
terms of hardware but because of the new
a15 bionic processor we have smart hdr4
and as you can see in the selfie shot
outside we're getting so much more
detail in that sunset instead of being
blown out with the iphone 12 and that
was one of the things that i hated about
my iphone 12 with these kind of selfies
now on the back we have as you guys see
the much bigger lenses we have the
little diagonal setup and that is
because the iphone 13 takes the same
best camera from the iphone 12 pro max
and puts it in this body so we have
larger sensors that image stabilization
lets in more light and then the
ultrawide was also much improved
compared to before now not only do you
get better image quality but in some of
these images that don't look that
different the new iphone 13 will take
the photo much quicker in night mode
because of the extra light so instead of
having to wait say two maybe three
seconds it could do it in one second and
that is definitely convenient and it
helps have nice sharp images instead of
sometimes having them turn out blurry
and along with that we also have some
differences for video if you like high
dynamic range video you can actually
shoot that up to 4k 60 with dolby vision
which is great and then we have the new
cinematic mode which allows you to get
blur with your video so right now i'm
recording vadim there with the camera
i'm going to tap on this ipad mini 6 box
you guys see we have portrait just like
for portrait photos but it's blurring
the video as well i'm going to tap back
at him so that is a really really cool
effect something that works well and of
course if it doesn't work out you can
actually disable it which is great it's
not built into the video and then with
that we can actually go to the
front-facing camera
and then i can also record cinematic
video with the front-facing camera so
that's something that is very cool and
it's exclusive to the iphone 13 line and
with all of those things compared let's
answer our initial question
is it worth the extra 100 more to get
the iphone 13 over the 12 or should you
save your money and is it worth
upgrading from a 12 to a 13. well for
the first question uh it is absolutely
worth the extra 100 to buy the iphone 13
there is no way i would buy the 12
unless maybe you're buying a used one
for like 500 bucks or something like
that but the price difference the extra
hundred dollars is well worth it first
off you get the extra storage that alone
costs you 50 bucks more for the iphone
12 so that's only 50 difference for the
two and a half hours better battery life
better cpu and graphics performance
brighter display less dimming when
you're outside and it's hot with that
you get the new cameras that are much
improved you get the cinematic mode
you have just so many other little
things that they've updated it is
absolutely worth spending the extra
fifty dollars or a hundred dollars if
you don't even need that extra storage
now with that is it worth upgrading from
a 12 to a 13. this is where i would say
no i would not do that if you already
have a 12 i would wait one extra year
or if you do want to upgrade in that
case don't get the iphone 13 go spend a
little bit more money and get the 13 pro
this thing has a lot of improvements
much faster graphics better uh
performance overall you get the pro
motion display a lot more if you guys
want you guys can check out our actual
video on this phone and if you're
interested and you're wondering maybe i
should maybe i shouldn't i will actually
be doing a comparison after one week of
using these the real world differences
um and if it's worth the extra 200 bucks
jumping from here to here you guys can
subscribe to see that video so there you
guys go make sure to check out the
anchor charge down below click that
button above to subscribe to help us
also reach our goal of a million
subscribers check out one of those great
videos right over there this has been
max and i will see you in the next video
[Music]